We have seen that the
binomial distribution plays
an important role in the study
of the Bernoulli process.
And the reason is that the
binomial distribution describes
the number of arrivals during
a fixed number of slots.
We will now develop
an approximation
to the binomial
distribution that
applies to one
particular regime,
and that regime is when we have
a very large number of slots,
but we have a small probability
of success in each slot.
And this is in a way so that the
product of these two numbers,
which is the expected
number of successes,
is a moderate number.
One example where such
a situation might arise
is the following.
Suppose you're interested
in earthquakes in your city,
and you divide time
into slots of one hour.
During each hour,
the probability
of having a noticeable
earthquake in your city
would be a very small number.
On the other hand, if
you're interested in a time
frame of five
years, there's going
to be many hours
during that time frame,
so that n would be quite large.
But the expected
number of earthquakes
over a period of five years
should be a moderate number.
And one can think
of other situations
where this regime might arise.
The one particular
situation that
will be very
interesting for us is
going to be when we try
to take a continuous time
approximation of the
Bernoulli process
by dividing time into
very small slots,
so that we have many slots, but
a small probability of success
during each one of those slots.
So to start, let us look at
the form of the binomial PMF.
And let us just try to develop
an approximation to this PMF,
when we fix k to be
particular constant number,
and then take the limit as
n goes to infinity and p
goes to 0, but in a way that
lambda remains constant.
And in particular,
because of this relation
here, we will have p
equal to lambda over n.
So let us take this expression
and start rewriting it.
Let us look at the ratio of
n factorial divided by this.
The denominator has the
product of all numbers going up
to n minus k.
So by dividing by this number,
what is left out of the n
factorial is only the terms
that go up to n minus k plus 1.
Then we have, in the
denominator, the factor
of k factorial.
Now p is equal to lambda over
n, so this term becomes lambda
to the k divided by n to the k.
And similarly,
for the last term,
we have 1 minus lambda over
n to the power n minus k.
Now let us rearrange terms.
Here, we have a product of
k terms in the numerator.
Here, we have n
multiplying itself k times.
So we can take a factor
of n and place it
underneath each
one of those terms
to obtain n over n times
n minus 1 over n times--
we continue this way all the
way to n minus k plus 1 divided
by n.
Take this term, k
factorial, move it
underneath the
lambda to the k term,
and then let us
split this last term
into 2 pieces in this manner.
And now let us start taking
limits as n goes to infinity.
The first term that we
have here is equal to 1.
How about the second term?
n divided by n is equal
to 1, 1 over n goes to 0,
so this term also
converges to 1.
And by a similar argument, all
of the terms in this product,
including this
one, converge to 1.
The term lambda k
over k factorial
remains exactly as is.
And now, let us
look at this term.
This is probably familiar.
There is a basic
fact which tells us
that if we take this
expression and raise it
to the nth power, what
we get is e to the minus
lambda in the limit
as n goes to infinity.
So using this basic
result, this term
becomes e to the minus lambda.
And finally, let's
look at the last term.
Remember that k is
fixed, is a constant.
1 minus lambda over
n converges to 1,
and when we raise that
number to the k-th power,
we still get a 1 in the limit.
So the only terms that
are left are here,
and essentially,
what we have just
established is
that in the limit,
the probability of k arrivals
in a Bernoulli process
or the binomial
probability evaluated
at k, in the limit, as n goes
to infinity and p goes to 0,
is given by this formula, here.
This is the formula
for the Poisson PMF.
And so what we have established
is that the binomial PMF
converges to a
Poisson PMF when we
take the limit in
this particular way.